the story continues doomed to hell on
earth back at last after days of hard
fighting in space you've returned home
on well-earned leave you're one of
Earth's crack soldiers hard-bitten
tough and heavily armed with the alien
invasion struck Mars you were the first
on the scene by killing killing and
killing you won you stopped the invasion
saved Mars base and became a war hero
what they don't talk about so much is
that you were the only survivor but
that's all behind you now you've quit
the military and are heading home your
draw pawns with a crunch you all put her
up and look out damn the city ahead is
on fire what the devil is going on you
stagger forward clutching your sidearm
packs of refugees are fleeing the
flaming metropolis a band of them shriek
in terror you squint what's that
someone is attacking the refugees you
rush up and blast away killing the
troublemaker
it looks like a human but something is
wrong his mouth is filled with
half-chewed flesh and he's all messed up
like a zombie from a bad horror movie oh
not again you can feel it it's all
starting again just like on Mars first
people are taken over turned into
cannibal things then the real horror
starts the deformed monstrosities
side but now it's on earth it turns out
that the invaders are all over monsters
range from Tokyo to Timbuktu from
Stockholm to Scranton billions are dead
some people have been transformed into
flesh-eating mutants but a few a very
few are still alive and fully human the
wise men of humanity have evolved the
plan to save what's left of the human
race
they have built enormous ships to carry
the remaining people into space safely
away from the ruined world unfortunately
Earth's only ground spaceport has just
been taken over by the demons they've
instituted some sort of force field a
fleam barrier over the port no ships can
land or take off you got to go back into
the action the pathetic remnants of
Earth soldiers are making an assault on
the invaders at the spaceport if you win
you might be able to turn off the
barrier so that the ships can leave and
how most sapiens may not go extinct just
yet if you lose that's it humanity is
history you and your comrades make their
attack soon brave men drop like flies
you lose track of your friends though
sometimes you can hear them scream when
they die then the sounds of combat echo
from deep within the Starbase something
hisses with rage from the steel tunnels
ahead they know you're here
they have no pity
no mercy take no quarter and crave none
they're the perfect enemy in a way no
one's left but you you and then
you